save if i'm not a vegetarian would i be
safe if i cook on sabbah
would i be saved if i cook for those who
are needy
okay if i cook on sabbath
well let me come closer will i be saved
if you read exodus 16 verse 26 to 30
gol told the israelites seeth what he
shall
see today cook on the preparation day
because tomorrow the next day is the
sabbath l white tells us
there is to be no cooking on sabbath but
the bible said that
she does say you may warm the food
no cooking on sabbath
now the question is will i go to heaven
or hell if i cook on sabbath
people are lost for disobeying god
we are lost for disobeying god
god told the israelites the food you
prepare on friday
will remain fresh on sabbath because
there should be
no cooking on sabbath and the food
remain fresh god is the same
can he keep your food fresh on sabbath
if you're cooking on friday
yes there's to be no
cooking on sabbath
next question how about being vegetarian
would i be safe if i'm not a vegetarian
[Laughter]
will i be saved if i'm not a vegetarian
you will be saved
if you ignore god's conviction regarding
your health habits
if god has given you light that meat
is harmful you continue to eat it
you have condemned yourself
are you with me you here's what john 3
19 says
and this is the condemnation that light
is coming to the world now
has the world receive light regarding
diet yes or no
yes you talk to any medical association
the heart association the cancer
association the
in the recommendations for diet they
tell you either cut out meat
or reduce it drastically because meat
was
not originally god's plan for us genesis
1 29
and god said behold i have given given
you every herb bearing seed
which is upon the face of all the earth
and every tree in the which is the fruit
of a tree
yielding seed to you it shall be for
meat
even for the animals they were to eat
vegetarian
a meal now ellen white writes i don't
recall where
god allowed sinners to eat meat
to shorten their lives
he allowed them to eat meat to shorten
their lives
let me ask you this if you plant
a seed in the ground after a few days
what happens it grows if you plant a
chicken
leg in the ground after a few days what
happens
nothing worms now when we plant things
in our stomach
you plant seeds they release life you
plant dead flesh
nothing it was never
god's will that we eat meat
god's preference is a vegetarian diet
and if he convicts you
and you resist the conviction you have
condemned yourself
not god you by your choice